[Music]
welcome back here's the picture of the
normally busy streets in Atlanta now
nearly deserted as Georgia's governor
orders the state to shelter in place
amid the corner virus pandemic joining
me right now is Georgia congressman Doug
Collins the ranking Republican on House
Judiciary Committee and congressman so
it's a pleasure to see you thank you so
much for being here was it too little
too late in terms of they stay in place
order in Georgia just Friday no yeah no
I don't think so I think it was it was
coming I would remember we had a lot of
our local counties municipalities that
had already been taking this lead and
the governor had been you know watching
that and I think now it's just it
confirms it all over the state and we're
Georgians are tough and we're making
headway in it this is still very active
in certain areas but you know I'm
confident hospitals or local officials
will continue to and state officials
will keep doing their job so congressman
you have been really showing such
leadership on your committee judiciary
and of course have been dealing with a
lot of back-and-forth with your
colleagues on the left now the Speaker
Nancy Pelosi says she wants to
investigate President Trump again this
time she's going to create a commission
to investigate the administration's
kovin 19 response Adam Schiff is
proposing a separate 911 style
Commission with subpoena power they want
more subpoena power here on these
commissions your reaction is this what's
going on now in terms of your committees
you know if there was a possibility
that's why I keep my hair short in
Congress Maria's not to pull it out
because every time we turn around the
Speaker Pelosi Adam Schiff all they want
to do is take any environment they can
and turn it to attack the president the
president is doing a good job the
president's working hard he's on TV
every day he's talking to the American
people every day he's got his vice
president pens leaving the task force
all these leaders leading and what do we
hear from Speaker Pelosi and now Adam
Schiff is that they want to invest to
have these Commission's or these 9/11
Commission's to investigate the
president all they've ever done it's
sort of amazing I heard a quote
yesterday from Speaker Pelosi I think
she said about this commission that
where there's money is there's mischief
I mean that's pretty rich coming from
basically the speaker who's the Pied
Piper of pork who tried to put
everything into this bill and was
worried about where it's going now why
don't we focus on helping the American
people do like the president is asked
let's get the money to where it needs to
go let's help our health care officials
health our hospitals let's help
businesses get back to work just like
you've been talking about on the show
this morning this is something we've got
to get through and then recover from and
just to simply do this out to attack and
basically say we're gonna follow this
president it's just it's just randomly
what we've seen the last year and a half
and it's making frankly it's just
painful